one of the Americans behind the infamous
Trump dossier was on Capitol Hill today
trying to explain the complicated web of
intrigue and information surrounding
that document the fact that Bruce or is
still a high-ranking Justice Department
official and his wife worked for the
company behind the dossier made the
situation as you can imagine even more
precarious chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge reports
from Capitol Hill
[Music]
Justice Department official Bruce or
whose portfolio included drugs and gangs
not Russia ignored Fox's questions as he
arrived on Capitol Hill with a
closed-door deposition under way
Republican lawmakers set or told his FBI
contacts there were issues with the
Trump dossier and its author former
British spy Christopher Steele who had
an anti-trump bias sources tell Fox News
the evidence suggests the national
security court was kept in the dark when
it authorized a surveillance warrant for
Trump campaign aide Carter page not only
did the FBI know that the dossier was
unverified but they also knew that there
was real credibility issues another
lawmaker said Orr's answers about the
timing and handling of the dossier do
not line up with other witnesses
including former FBI lawyer at Lisa
Paige who sent anti Trump texts and
Glenn Simpson whose firm Fusion GPS was
paid by the DNC and Clinton campaign for
the anti-trump research there are a
number of factual conflicts either Bruce
lures lion or Glenn Simpson's lion and
in another circumstance either Bruce
lures lion or at least a pages lion
after the FBI fired Steel's a source
over his media contacts documents show
steel used or as a back-channel to
maintain contact with the bureau and
pass along information or his wife Nelly
worked for fusion GPS on Russia
lawmakers point to a financial conflict
although Bruce or would appear to claim
to be without partisan his wife since
2015 knowingly worked on the find dirt
on Trump try to make this connection
with the Russians for which he was paid
and he didn't properly disclose your
deposition concluded here just an hour
ago after seven hours of grilling
Democratic lawmakers did not attend
leaving the questioning to their
staffers and lawyers brett catherine
herridge on the hill Catherine thank you